voici un spa pour pomme on les trempe
dans de l'eau chaude à 49°rés pendant 2
minutes et on s'est aperçu que ça fait
une sorte de traitement contre les
pourriture et en sortie frigo 2 3 4 mois
plus tard on a beaucoup moins de
pourriture sur les pommes donc ça limite
le gaspillage la perte alimentaire et ça
nous permet aussi de limiter des
traitements fongies au Vergés le
principe de la thermothérapie appliqué
au fruit c'est la vocation de ce centre
de recherche trouver des solutions
techniques innovantes et viables pour
les arboriculteurs donc les les pluies
ont entraîné une projection de de sport
sur les armes donc là on est en risque
maladie c'est de c'est de trouver des
nouvelles méthodes de lutte des nouvau
des nouvelles molécules en fait nouvell
molécule que ça soit en en conventionnel
ou en
bio cette station du Sud Touren a été
créée en 1980 par l'interprofession elle
possède le plus grand verger de France
28 hectares dédiés aux pommes poire et
petits fruits rouges comme le cassis et
la mytille ces études sont désormais
intimement lié au dérèglement climatique
on s'aperçoit qu'il y a il y a
énormément de de de nouveaux problèmes
qui apparaissent que ce soit des
problèmes de pourriture que ça soit des
problèmes de de maladie que ce soit des
problèmes d'insectes qui qui
apparaissent aujourd'hui qu'on avait pas
il y a 5 ans par exemple
alors ici on est sur une parcelle de
mytill et on évalue des variétés des
nouvelles variétés de mytill on regarde
leur comportement agronomique les
rendements le goût de ces
variétés on fait aussi des essais pour
trouver des alternatives aux herbicides
comme vous voyez ici vous avez des
bâches vous avez différents types de de
paillage organique et on regarde quelles
sont les techniques qui sont les plus
appropriées pour se passer des
herbicides
les ravageurs comme les pucerons sont
aussi traqués et traités si possible
sans produit de synthèse on cherche à
mieux connaître le cycle des ravageurs
pour identifier le moment de très précis
on va pouvoir utiliser un produit de
biocontrôle ça peut être de l'argile ça
peut être des huiles essentielles ça
peut être des huiles
végétales il faut également prendre en
compte les phénomènes climatiques
aujourd'hui récurrent la grê elle la
sécheresse ou la canicule la
productivité reste donc au cœur des
recherches avec des innovations parfois
surprenantes ici par exemple on a pris
un arbre on l'a complètement
couché et on l'a donc on l'a attaché
pour faire ressortir tous les axes à la
verticale ce qui va permettre d'avoir
une haie fruitière qui est beaucoup
moins large et donc préparer le verger
par exemple à la mécanisation à la
robotisation objectif final satisfait
faire le consommateur quitte à
influencer ses attentes pour tendre vers
des pratiques
verteuses on ne traite pas pour le
plaisir on traite parce que le
consommateur ou en tout cas les gens qui
nous achètent les fruits le demandent
donc si effectivement on a une pression
qui est un peu moins forte on pourra
adapter des techniques qui sont plus
respectueuse de
l'environnement chaque année le centre
de la Morinière réalise en moyenne une
trentaine d'ex ent sur une centaine de
variétés en bio comme en
conventionnel